laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight general
mark milley has exposed himself to
possible charges under multiple
provisions of the uniform code of
military justice we're going to lay them
out for you tonight also polls in
california the recall election closed at
the bottom of our hour
could there be any surprises a report
from the ground later tonight
and what do aoc
and fauci have in common i'll reveal
but first
general millie's insurrection that's the
focus of tonight's angle
all year long democrats and trump haters
have clung to the events of january 6
with a white-knuckled death grip
they claim a riot that the capitol
police should have been prepared for was
actually an insurrection the shortest in
world history by the way but today we
learn the truth there was indeed an
insurrection being planned around that
time in washington but it took place at
the pentagon
and its chief architect was general mark
milley
in a new book by bob woodward and robert
acosta we learned that millie chairman
of the joint chiefs jumped the chain of
command and then essentially installed
himself an unelected military officer as
the nation's commander-in-chief
milli was overseeing the mobilization of
america's national security state
without the knowledge of the american
people or the rest of the world
some might contend that million
overstepped his authority but he
believed his actions were in good faith
a precaution to ensure that there was no
historic rupture in the international
order no accidental war with china or
others and no use of nuclear weapons
notice the framing yes he may have
violated both the military code of the
constitution but it was all in good
faith grounded in good intentions
for the international order now what an
arrogant imperious boob but none of us
should be surprised about millie he's
always craved acceptance and approval
from the elites
most evident when he issued that
embarrassing on-cam apology in june 2020
for having walked across lafayette
square with president trump during the
blm unrest that sparked a national
debate
about the role of the military in civil
society i should not have been there
my presence in that moment and in that
environment
created a perception of the military
involved in domestic politics
as a commissioned uniformed officer it
was a mistake that i have learned from
you've learned
nothing sir
in fact getting involved in domestic
politics is exactly what you did six
months after that embarrassing
performance
if millie was so gravely concerned about
what he saw and heard from president
trump okay he should have resigned his
position instead if these reports are
accurate he chose not only to violate
his chain of command
but to have separate track conversations
with the speaker of the house nancy
pelosi on january 8th
about the nuclear football
she asked millie what precautions are
available to prevent an unstable
president from initiating military
hostilities or from accessing launch
codes and ordering a nuclear strike
millie assured her that there were a lot
of checks in the system
pelosi then told millie trump's crazy
you know he's crazy he's crazy
and what he did yesterday is further
evidence of his craziness milly replied
i agree with you on everything
well nut bag nancy wanted him to
confiscate the nuclear launch codes
denying president trump the ability to
wage war
although millie reportedly waved her off
it doesn't matter
by simply having that conversation
millie thrust himself into a political
role to which he was not elected
as a commissioned officer millie answers
to his commander-in-chief not to pelosi
or schumer or a foreign leader speaking
of which
perhaps the most disturbing aspect of
this entire issue
involves millie's secret conversations
before the election
with world leaders including his chinese
counterpart one call took place on
october 30th 2020 four days before the
election general lee i want to assure
you that the american government is
stable and everything is going to be
okay
you know i've known each other for five
years now if we're going to attack i'm
going to call you ahead of time it's not
gonna be a surprise
okay
i don't care what he thought trump might
do
millie had zero authority to make these
phone calls
in the absence of a specified unlawful
order by president trump
millie was engaged in potentially
treasonous conduct
he took on the political role that he
had decried in his june 2020 apology
of course the media spent most of today
blocking and tackling for millie
because let's face it any enemy of trump
is a friend of theirs
he seems to be the greatest patriot that
was on duty during the previous
administration i have to say is emerging
as a pretty important and heroic
american figure in this era i don't
blame general milley for any of this
it is much i blame donald trump he felt
he couldn't trust trump
and needed to take all necessary
precautions to prevent him from doing
something dangerous
weeks ago i was the first in the media
to call for millie to step down over his
role in the deadly afghanistan
withdrawal today
these revelations were enough to push
marco rubio rand paul and others to call
for millie's firing as well good for
them
and after four years think about this of
liberal journalists squawking that trump
was like a tyrant authoritarian figure
he demanded personal loyalty of everyone
at work for him
woodward writes that it was millie who
demanded allegiance
not to the u.s military code or the
constitution but to himself
during the final days of the trump white
house he allegedly said to his top
officers
no matter what you're told you do the
procedure you do the process and i'm
part of that procedure he then went
around the room looked each officer in
the eye and asked them to verbally
confirm they understood
millie considered it
an oath
as the angle has noted on many occasions
the u.s military needs a top-down reform
led by generals like millie our military
the best equipped in the world hasn't
won a major war outright since world war
ii
it's been marred by one failure after
another failure is not due to the
valiant efforts of our enlisted men and
women but due to their leadership
which has become a woke joke
in recent weeks they've been exposed as
either incompetent corrupt or both
from the appalling afghanistan
withdrawal to the chinese humiliation of
our diplomatic corps we've seen an
administration just totally adrift
and a democrat party
unwilling to level with the american
people about the stark danger we're in
as a result of this ineptitude
among today's military leadership
political correctness diversity
inclusion
they're more fervently prized and
studied than any plan for victory on the
battlefield or at an airport
as for punishment from millie
he should be court-martialed and
dishonorably discharged for his role in
what was a lot closer to an insurrection
than anything we saw on january 6th
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else